all right Henry come on in okay Henry
happy holidays
as people can probably tell we're
celebrating the holidays a little early
oh yeah because we want to spread a
little Christmas cheer because you have
a new holiday movie coming out so I
thought we'd celebrate with a good
old-fashioned game of nog pause we're
keeping it classy I've played Reglan
really you've never I think I've only
played it once really and I didn't win
I'll tell you I really don't remember
the rest of the night we are just
missing one crucial ingredient I'm going
to pour a tiny bit just okay watch this
Henry this is how we do it and take this
is how you do it this is why I don't
remember the night okay the rules are
simple
you toss a ball into one of my cups yeah
and I have to drink and vice versa you
got it got it okay and what we're
playing for so glad you asked the winner
gets to go home with a highly coveted
first annual nog pawn world championship
[Applause]
let's take positions you ready to start
thank yous first okay well I'm gonna ask
a question while we're doing words
because I'm trying to throw you off your
game okay what last Christmas about
because I'm excited Oh Amelia cards
character Kate wants to be a singer well
she's kind of having that quarter life
crisis that we all sort of often get
ourselves into and she meets a young man
called Tom who gives her a different
perspective on life and there's George
Michael music George where did you grow
up I grew up I split time between
Malaysia and the UK so sorry so from 10
onwards I was I was in the UK so those
are the best years of like Christmas
present yeah I love UK cost and any time
in England like at Christmastime it's
like more magical so what is your
favorite Christmas movie I'll go first
white Christmas elf is what was your job
before acting I used to work in a salon
doing sort of blowouts cuts dries like
mess
more often than not I'm doing her hair
for whenever we're not red coffee you
see my wife like I usually do the
blowout like you're kind of nailing it
was kind of that Chelsea wives blowout
which was like big and voluminous and
sexy I'm gonna
you know I hear a trooper hmm Oh Lord
you're gonna kick it hot is a game I go
one last one as well I get this one this
last one you have to do whatever Rowell
and oh okay the road you were closest to
this and I'll just do you kind of I
think baited me a bit and said you'd
weren't really good at this and then
kind of like killed me about a fight a
couple times come on come on horse I did
okay I'm walking out with this what are
you talking about only coming back next
year when I do another Christmas movie I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this